I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I heard that that most of the
stories we have about ourselves and our
heads aren't even true because they
aren't even the original story and
because I think you do those little
tweaks every single time you have the
memory until the original story and the
one that you carry around don't even
look the same next to each other right
this takes a lot of patience and
self-reflection to even step back enough
to recognize that instead of just like
going through you know being you know
the human race and you're just racing
towards the next thing just slowed down
enough
what other like tell me about those
businesses that tell me about the
businesses that failed well I mean I
can't even say that they failed because
they never even launched so I mean I
feel like I failed more than they did
because the ideas were good well they're
in a holding pattern then yeah what's in
a holding pattern an entire ebook I'm
having why the splits huh it has video
material with it it's quite a collection
of things I worked really hard on it
yeah and then I just got so scared that
nobody would buy it and it would make me
look stupid but everyone would see that
I released this thing that completely
flopped that I ended up not releasing it
just that was that was where it stopped
as you just said and I'm not ready well
I mean it was a way longer conversation
and far more drawn-out but that was
really the message behind it all and I
was gonna start a hat company like
making baseball caps and sort of like
vintage style trucker hats and I did a
ton of work on that one and then the
same thing I was like well nobody's
gonna buy this and I'm gonna look
ridiculous and it's kind of the same
story that keeps coming up like and it
usually comes up not even at a time when
I'm really thinking about the sales of
something that's kind of how it
manifests but I think when it really
comes up is back to that old story of I
can't figure it out like I'd get to a
step in the process that maybe involved
paperwork or some sort of accounting and
business or math that I didn't
understand well and yeah rather than
sort of looking in the mirror about that
I would tell a different story that I
was familiar with that was nobody's
gonna buy this and I'm gonna look
ridiculous it's gonna flop and I kind of
let that take it away rather than
recognizing that I had just simply
encountered an obstacle that I didn't
feel I could overcome do you
have a hard time asking for help less so
now which is probably why this company
is actually gonna launch but I guess and
things like that I do it's weird I don't
have a hard time asking for favors
mm-hmm but I think I have a hard time
asking for help because in doing that
there's an admission of I don't know
everything and I think that's sometimes
a hard one for me to make sure
[Music]